I have the two best guys in the world so
I'm really happy
Megan Marco and Prince Harry left baby
Archie in Canada following their royal
bombshell the palace has gone into
serious crisis mode it is on lockdown a
source tells ET that Archie was not with
Harry and Megan in London this week as
the couple shocked the world and the
monarchy with their announcement to step
back as senior members of the royal
family from brexit tomb exit as the way
it's being described here according to
our source the eight-month-old son of
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex did not
return to the UK with the couple
following the family's six-week vacation
in Canada instead Archie avoided all the
drama by staying in the care of Megan's
best friends Canadian stylist
Jessica Mulroney and a nanny the source
also revealed that Megan has flown back
to Canada to be with her son the dream
family had previously spent Thanksgiving
Christmas and New Year's Eve together in
British Columbia where they were spotted
hiking with friends but since that time
Harry and Megan returned to London made
an appearance at the Canada House and
dropped the massive bombshell that they
plan to become financially independent
and split their time between North
America and the UK there are talks
ongoing and they will be ongoing for
many days to come the Sussex is went
nuclear when they issued that statement
the palace weren't ready for it
according to a royal expert Katie Nichol
the Sussex is had been in touch with
senior members of the royal family while
they were visiting Canada but the
announcement wasn't part of the deal at
the time of the announcement a source
told ET that the Queen had asked Prince
Harry to not release his shocking
statement we also learned that the 93
year old Queen is devastated about their
vision to distance themselves from the
royal family there are so many things
that still need to be addressed and of
course a meeting that at some point is
going to have to happen between the
Queen and her grandson and now get this
Oprah Winfrey is getting caught up in
the drama on Thursday a publication
reported that the television icon
advised the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
to step back from the British monarchy
which lady Oh totally denies she told ET
in a statement Megan and Harry do not
need my help in figuring out what's best
for them I care about them both and
support whatever decisions they make for
their family
[Music]